[Musique]
voici la poursuite 14 millions de
dollars pour dommages et intérêts et
bris de contrat 7 millions de dollars
pour violation des droits et libertés et
un autre 7 millions pour dommages
exemplaires et punitifs
la poursuite est sans équivoque le
gouvernement fédéral n'aurait pas rempli
son premier devoir de protéger ces
diplomates
au total 14 personnes cinq diplomates et
leurs familles qui sont revenus avec ce
qu'ils appellent le syndrome de la
havane et se sont sentis abandonnés par
ottawa
nous avons des symptômes de commotion
cérébrale sans jamais avoir eu de trauma
notre cerveau ne fonctionnent plus
normalement
j'ai encore plusieurs symptômes les
principaux étant mot tête migraine
fatigue excessive depuis novembre 2018
ils sont suivis par l'institut de
recherche sur le cerveau à ottawa et le
centre de réparation du cerveau de
l'université de dalhousie en nouvelle
écosse ils font partie d'un projet de
recherche sur les lésions cérébrales et
subi une batterie de tests
on nous injecte un agent contrastant
dans le sang pour pouvoir voir dans
notre cerveau s'il ya des fuites de la
barrière hémato-encéphalique et avec
l'aide d'un magnéto encéphalogramme on
voit de plus près ce qui se passe dans
leur cerveau on nous a posé une centaine
d'électrodes sur la tête et on mesure l
activité électrique de notre cerveau et
puis à chaque fois qu'il y avait une
diminution de l'activité électrique qui
étaient détectés par une électrode sa
enregistré et on pouvait voir s'il y
avait des dysfonctions au niveau
cérébral et chaque fois les tests sont
concluants et confirme qu'il y a une
vision cérébrales traumatiques
le docteur dogme smith de l'université
de pennsylvanie a diagnostiqué que des
diplomates avaient des symptômes de
commotion cérébrale après avoir suivi
ses présumées attaques les diplômes est
aujourd'hui prise en charge par ottawa
reproche au gouvernement d'avoir attendu
treize mois avant de s'occuper d'eux on
a par tous les moyens tenter de faire
reconnaître notre gouvernement que notre
situation était bien réelle n'était pas
d'origine psychologique
il ya eu des erreurs on estime que nos
besoins
notre santé n'ont pas toujours été la
priorité
pourquoi pourquoi on n'a pas eu accès
aux ressources spécialisées nécessaire
ce n'est pas le résultat du hasard c'est
le résultat de décisions
cette négligence a eu un impact sur les
familles qui nous ont suivis à laval on
a continué à envoyer des familles avec
des enfants
alors que nous on levait le drapeau
rouge en disant attention on est malade
qui c'est pas normal aujourd'hui sont
représentés par l'avocat john phillips
le même qui a représenté omar khadr
c'est en septembre 2010 est que la
sphère cubaine éclater au grand jour à
washington 24 diplomates américains sont
évacués d'urgence de laval
on parle alors d'une attaque acoustique
qui aurait ciblé des diplomates
américains ils se plaignent de maux de
tête de nausées de perte d'équilibré
mais cette mystérieuse attaque serait
aussi survenus dans les résidences
diplomatiques canadiennes au printemps
et selon ces diplomates la volonté
n'était tout simplement pas là quand il
ya une priorité une décision de haut
niveau politique ça bouge vite et il y a
des ressources de débloquer la grc
enquêtent depuis le début pour connaître
la cause de ces syndromes mais le
mystère demeure entier en avril 2018
ottawa décide de faire de la vanne à
postes diplomatiques non accompagnés
c'est à dire sans sa mue et en janvier
ottawa confirme qu'un 14e diplomates et
rapatrié d'urgence car il souffre des
mêmes symptômes de commotion affaires
mondiales réduit son personnel
diplomatique de moitié et passe de 16 à
8 diplomate
affecté à la havane la santé des
diplomates est une priorité du
gouvernement tout en réitérant de bonnes
relations avec cuba
j'aimerais qu'on puisse faire toute la
lumière sur les processus de décisions
internes qui ont mené à l'inaction du
gouvernement pendant une longue période
dans ce dossier ma fille rentre avec des
symptômes
lorsqu'elle revient avec des maux de
tête des pertes équilibre
je n'ai personne à qui appeler pour
avoir des réponses pour noter pour
étudier ou pour comprendre
personnes pour la plupart le poste de la
havane était une affectation de rêve qui
s'est terminée en véritable cauchemar